all right let's go to Tom from Jersey
listen if there's ever been a time to go
to New Jersey for sit for saving us I
think it's right now Tom from Jersey
what's going on
hey David can you hear me yes I can
thank goodness
yeah I was getting where it goes like is
this like a it might be the next one but
um
just you know I live in Jersey which is
great it's a blue state I'm really happy
with how our state government functions
but there is one issue I have that I've
also noticed is an issue with a lot of
other blue States in fact I think that
someone from The New York Times
something about this okay New Jersey for
being the most diverse state in the
country is also school-wise one of the
most segregated and in Connecticut which
is also supposed to be liberal State
it's I believe it's to say with the
largest income disparity because you
have like wealthy people live in
Stanford yep right next to low-income
people who live in Newport I mean with
Bridgeport and New Haven correct and
Washington they have really
um really favorable corporate tax rates
for like Amazon and in California they
talk about the housing but whenever they
try to build uh multi-family or single
or affordable housing a lot of people
who live in like San Francisco or stuff
get really upset so why do you think we
keep seeing this issue of these liberal
states or people who live in these
liberal areas who right I just seem to
be helping push inequality or helping or
not super for uh invested in trying to
attack systems or reform systems that
cause this type of inequality I'm not
saying that the answer is an interesting
one this has been studied so the if I
understand correctly Tom the main
question you're asking is
it's liberals and blue states that talk
about fixing income inequality yet it's
many of those very blue states that have
the most income inequality right I mean
is that more or less what you're saying
yeah basically yeah so two things on
that number one the examples you're
giving are absolutely accurate when it
comes to particularly Connecticut
however if you zoom out and look at the
country in total
it's only slightly worse of an issue
overall in blue versus red States the
inequality issue it is an issue so
you're right in your analysis but it's
only to a relatively small degree so on
average blue states are a little more
unequal than red States but not by a
huge margin but it's sort of a result of
the fact that blue states are
economically more successful and it's
basically a result of the fact that
on average blue states have higher
incomes average incomes and that is
pulled up by Blue States having more
wealthy people and that increases the
level of inequality by virtue of having
those additional wealthy people so it's
a result both of the successes of those
very policies and the fact that that is
what increases the very inequality that
these states want to fix
okay I always knew yeah I never I always
knew that we were better at it than the
red States but I always thought to
myself just because we're better than
them doesn't mean we shouldn't look into
it
absolutely and there's if you Google
liberal states and income inequality
you'll find a ton of good resources on
this it's been widely studied
yeah I mean no but you know I'd never
want to live in a red State I'd stay in
Jersey or New York my whole life all
right well that's you're right my friend
all right have a great day okay thank
you there's Tom from Jersey Tom is not
leaving Jersey is the message we are
getting or he'll go to New York which is
also completely fine all right let's
take a very quick break I'm taking more
calls it's just I need a very quick
break
hang on and then we'll get right back to
it